[Music]
chad is in minneapolis hey chad how are
you
better than i deserve how are you just
the same sir what's up
so i've got a question um
my fiance and i have very different
views on money we're going to get
married next next summer
congratulations
yep thank you
grew up on a farm working saving you
know striving for a better life it
wasn't that i was destitute when i was
growing up but you know it was it was
not always the easiest thing um her mom
had her my my fiance's
grandfather
passed away and her mom inherited
millions of dollars
never had to work and ended up raising
nine kids on her own after her dad left
um and sort of abandoned the family
and then ended up using the money that
she had inherited to
manipulate the kids into doing things
into
thinking the way that she did doing
things for her
but ultimately has left sort of a bad
taste in her mouth with money
how do i work with her to show her that
money isn't
intrinsically evil um i am i'm the
breadwinner i i have a very good career
um you know i make about 120 she makes
38.
how do i work with her to show her that
money's not bad
how old are you guys
uh 36 and 38. okay
okay
um either one of you been married before
both of us have actually so we're we're
combining
i've got four boys she has two girls
okay
well let me tell you some statistical
things to think about and these are
things you can go over with her
okay
um one of the things you want to do
anytime you want to enter into anything
in business we would study
if you want to enter into marketing we
would study marketing and and emulate
best practices find best practices and
find where the landmines are we want to
avoid the mind landmines keep from
getting your leg blown off right and we
want to emulate people who are winning
we want to copy the things that the
people that are winning are doing agreed
okay so here's what you guys are facing
it's not insurmountable by the way
but it is an uphill climb
you have three major strikes against
your marriage before it even starts
you don't address these
i'll give you a high probability of
failure
okay
number one
her
family upbringing was toxic
she comes from a highly dysfunctional
family number one
hard to have relationships when you have
come from a highly dysfunctional family
unless you've dealt with it
did i did i misstate that
no okay number two you both have failed
at marriage before and if you have not
healed through those failures and
learned from those failures um you will
replicate the exact same stupid crap
again
high probability of failure if you do
not deal with that that's right number
three
the number one cause of divorce in north
america today
money disagreements money fights and
money problems and you're already having
those
you have to solve all three of those
before the summer
and and to be honest with you so in in
both both of our um both of both of us
chose to leave our marriages
due to
a lot of issues unfortunately i we we
knew each other's um
exes so we we saw it there was a lot of
people that saw it um yeah wonderful you
still both failed at marriage listen
dude you got what i'm trying to tell you
is you guys need a lot of one-on-one
counseling
pre-marriage counseling to deal with
these three issues before you walk down
the aisle otherwise statistically you
have a very high probability of hitting
the wall yeah don't miss this i'm not
trying to say you can't make it i'm just
saying dude there's land mines
everywhere and i'm trying to guide you
through them and you need a coach a
counselor that they can talk to the two
of you that is excellent that is world
class this is not two little puppies
getting married and they need some
little pat on the hand pre-marriage
counseling you need to deal with divorce
healing you need to deal with her toxic
upbringing because her mother's crazier
than a freaking bean man what you
described to me is dangerous stuff
control and then on top of that you're
in total disagreement have different
value systems about money and you boiled
it down to she thinks money's evil
that's not the problem here that'll be
one of 14 things that come up while
y'all unpack this yeah chad i hope
you're hearing this you need to pause
this wedding date until this stuff gets
fixed we didn't say not marry her we
said pause well i don't even need to
pause it you just gotta do the work
between now and summer well i i
appreciate that dave that's very
optimistic i think it's pause until we
get healthy and on the same page of this
and i'd say this she's gonna have to see
a desired future that you both agree on
that money helps us get there that's
eventually where you're going to have to
get her if you can't agree about money
you're not going to agree about life
and you guys really do have some work to
do to get ready for this marriage i
think you can do it but you're not gonna
do it if you'd ignore it